[Music]
and more science of turmoil for the
struggling vice president tonight
because even the media mob is being
forced to acknowledge that whatever
appeal harris once had well it's
cratering by the second for example a
new piece in politico calls her quote a
one-time political rock star who is
having a brutal season at the polls and
of course the baffling moments are
showing no signs of slowing down watch
vice president harris struggled to
charge an electric vehicle can't make
this up
you usually can smell it and and you can
hear it you can hear the guzzling sound
right none of that but how would i know
that i don't
know that so typically uh excuse me yeah
so typically you come in here to wave
this car yeah and then what it would do
is it would authenticate uh and then the
light downstream
great job here with reaction fox news
contributors leo 2.0 terrell and jason
chaffetz jason you're laughing harder
you go first
and this is the person who's supposedly
in charge of the national space council
her job is to advise the president on
how we're going to operate in space she
can't even put a plug into a car
i mean
she is such a joke it's just an
embarrassment she should have hired
those child actors to show her how to
put a plug into an outlet
the child actors would have been better
that was part of the pr image makeover
nobody wants to work for her they say
it's a hostile work environment
leo your reaction
oh look everybody knows the fact she was
selected for vice president for two
reasons gender and skin color she has no
expertise she's not an expert on foreign
policy she's not expert on criminal
justice she was picked for the wrong
reason and look she runs away from a
tough issue immigration the border issue
she can't even she doesn't even know
what to do with electric car does she
hold the pump forever and ever she is
clueless and i have to be very clear
i've said this before her political
career is over in 2024 because she's
unlikable
well you know look she's losing all of
her staff she's hired pr people fire to
communications people nobody wants to
work with her they're using the term a
soul-crushing bully
i i mean
is that our vice president does she get
to take over something happens for joe
and joe ain't looking too good these
days jason
well she did redecorate her office and
and so that was a vital part of what she
did
yeah and she she
redid that and so look going into the to
the nomination she was in eighth place
in her home state of california even the
california democrats figured out that
she wasn't worth worth uh worth worthy
of this position
leo we're going to give you the last
four tonight soul crushing
yeah it
it looks it's a nightmare it's a
nightmare when we have to wake up
thinking either biden or kamal harris
two of the worst of all time in two of
the most powerful positions is a
horrible choice between the two of them
does
do you think joe biden
did you make anything real quick jason
chavets of the fact that they he kind of
moved away from her they didn't seem to
acknowledge each other at bob dole's
uh
funeral
yeah i mean clearly the president was
supposed to sit next to camalleris then
he whispered over to to jill biden and
said hey we need to switch seats he
didn't shake her hand didn't acknowledge
her and certainly didn't want to sit by
her
yeah unbelievable he was forced to make
detroit he was forced forced to make her
choice as vice president
why was he forced right quick why was he
forced oh come on because of all the all
the all the identity politics
he was forced to pick a female minority
he didn't want her oh all right thank
you both more hannity right after this
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else